wealth breakthroughs is an exclusive
video series where millionaires break
their silence on their usually hidden
secrets on how to stack up great wealth
it's like EES dropping on the private
conversations Rich folks have with each
other behind closed doors but I
partnered with the series Creator Jeff
Hayes to bring that VIP pass to you
right here today in this episode you'll
learn how to franchise your business the
easiest way to accumulate wealth how to
build a business that pays for your life
and the four key rules for starting a
business get ready to unlock wealth
building secrets and create a business
that works for you
enjoy hello and welcome to your wealth
breakthroughs bonus episode there were
so many great interviews 40 in all
there's no way we could possibly pack
every bit of wealth creating insight
into the 10 episode format of wealth
breakthroughs that's why we made this
bonus episode and will'll be giving
giving you hidden unaired footage all
throughout the year first up today we
have Eric Van Horn founder of franchise
Secrets Eric's going to show you the
best franchise to operate how to scale
multiple franchises even how to
eliminate the guesswork if you've been
curious about franchising but never took
the leap fact is done right franchising
is one of the easiest and most lucrative
ways to bring wealth breakthrough into
your life now let's talk to Eric to get
all the details enjoy
[Music]
Eric thanks for taking the time to sit
and talk with us it's my pleasure so
we're going to be talking about
franchising that's your area of
expertise really excited to have this
conversation because not many people
talk about this when we talk about
wealth and I think it's an important
area how did you get into it what what
brought you into doing what to you I
remember when I was a kid in high School
my dad was an entrepreneur as far as I
knew cuz he had a job and then lost his
job and then started his own business
and he was working a lot and working in
the business had employees and then one
day uh I came home from school and I
started to play out play in the yard
doing some fun stuff and then he was
there and was interacting with me and
little did I know that that was a
conscious decision that he made was to
spend time with us kids at that time and
I realized that I want to do that when
I'm grownup I want to be able to spend
time with my kids and Entrepreneurship
was the Avenue for that I didn't realize
it was going to be franchising until
years later so I had graduated from
college what did you study in school
business business administration right
and I went for two years and then I took
a year off and I traveled a bit and um
then came back and finished up my second
year uh second uh two years of school
and I graduated with a degree in
business and I was ready to go to law
school at that point and I took the
elsat and I was registered for school
and then I realized how much work it was
going to be that was the attorney route
was not going to give me the lifestyle
that I wanted and so I was in my early
20s and I started a landscaping company
I started this landscaping company and I
was mowing awn planting flowers for some
older lady and she came up to me and
gave me some water and said you know
basically Eric what do you want to do
when you grow up and I said I want to be
a real estate investor and then the next
thing that she said is like oh we did
that about 20 years ago and I said well
what do you mean she said we did it for
tax purposes back then we have this
condo down by the beach and I was in
Virginia beach at the time and and I was
just intrigued tell me more and she said
we just want to sell it now we want to
simplify our lives and we don't want the
headache of having a tenant in that
condo anymore and you know being a guy
that was wanting to be entrepreneurial I
said well how much do you want for it
and I didn't have any money at the time
you know I was about ready to go to law
school and she said we don't want
anything for it we just want someone to
take over our payments and so I was
studying real estate at the time and I
realized there was something uh back
then that was called an assumable
mortgage where I could really just
assume her mortgage and so I came back
to her house I delivered her an option
contract with $100 and the option
contract said I have the right to buy
your house in the next 30 days and with
no money down and she said all I want is
for someone to pay the closing cost and
so I called up my parents I said you're
not going to believe this but I have
this opportunity and you can uh buy this
house with me and we'll split the
profits 50/50 but I need you to come up
with the closing cost and so they wrote
the check for the closing cost and well
before that um they said Eric it sounds
too good to be true and my real estate
broker said I I don't know how Eric did
this but he did and I and if you guys
don't do this with him I will and so we
bought the house and a few months later
they bought me out my parents bought me
out of my portion and I had my first
large chunk of money it's not very large
now but at that time it was a lot of
seed money for me and I knew enough not
to go buy a new car or do something like
that and I had some friends looking at
some franchises at the time and I really
didn't even know what a franchise was I
went to business school and we really
didn't even talk about franchising and
so I ended up meeting uh some people
that were franchisees and then meet the
I was meeting the founder and I realized
well this is really interesting the
whole concept where there's something
that was uh a proven model that I could
step into and I don't have to do
everything from scratch and so I ended
up buying my first franchise in my
mid-20s what was that first franchise
that first franchise was Liberty Tax
Service and I had no desire to do
accounting or taxes and I don't think I
ever did a tax return as an owner of
that and it was a really good lesson in
business for me because I was a marketer
and this was really a marketing company
the product was taxes but the way to get
Revenue in the door was marketing and
then I wanted I was always looking for
opportunities and the founder of that
company at the time had started another
tax business so he had history in in the
business and he had history in selling a
lot of franchises so in addition to
owning the franchise I sent him an email
I said I would like to sell franchisees
I'd like to learn how to do that and he
said I'll never forget it he the reply
back in that email was uh show up on
this date and we'll give you a shot H
and so it was a challenge in a way right
and I knew that's how he operated but I
also knew that he mentored people in
group so that he spent an hour every day
at 4:00 or 4:00 meetings with all of the
franchise development reps which are
salespeople um and he spent an hour with
us telling us teaching us coaching us
and helping us help him sell franchises
so I wanted and then I realized being on
the inside of a franchise has its
benefits as well yeah so uh was that
franchise successful for you did it work
it was a challenge at first so I look
back and it was one of the toughest
franchises that I've ever owned and gone
on to own a number of them and that was
to that point it was a really tough
franchise it was a seasonal business and
getting into the seasonal business I
thought well I only have to work four
months out of the year but then you have
to hire new people every year and
there's just challenges that come along
with that and the industry went through
a lot of different changes so we were
constantly having to adjust uh from a
hiring standpoint and adjust from the
industry changes and just the way things
were going in that business it was a
really difficult business um and I owned
and ended up owning 12 stores oh 12 of
them yeah wow in Kansas City I had some
and then in Austin Texas I had some and
after owning them for about a year I
bought what's called an area development
and a lot of people know it as Master
franchising and I bought that with my
parents 50-50 Partners in Austin Texas
and so I remember at that time flying
into Austin and people when you're on an
airplane they ask what you do and I said
I own liberty taxes here and nobody knew
what that was so 10 years later almost
10 years later I flew into Austin
someone asked what what I did and I told
them they said you guys are everywhere
so I understood the power of franchising
I understood how you can quickly grow a
brand you can quickly grow a market and
as an area developer I took that market
I bought that entire region and we
started out with four franchisees and we
ended up with 42 locations and as a
master franchisee at the time I got half
of the royalties off of that so I was
building I was like a mini franchisor in
that market and and when I ended up
selling that that was my first real
large chunk of money that came into my
bank account that I'd never seen before
and that was seed money for the next
thing that I started to do so before we
get into that next thing uh so when you
had the the development deal you the
Master franchise so you were kind of
both selling franchises cuz it wasn't
you personally just going to put up all
42 correct you went and recruited a
bunch of people to put them up and you
had a piece of each one so you were
their partner in essence is that the
structure yeah I was and I was kind of
the middleman between the franchisee and
the franchise or and I would I would
sell and so that's why I wanted to work
at the corporate office to learn how to
sell so I didn't have to you know figure
that out myself so I was selling for
myself in Austin Texas and then I was
selling in other parts of the country
for the corporate office so anybody that
was looking at a franchise they would
come to me and then I developed a
personal relationship with them and and
I got to know them and their families
and so I really wanted to see them
succeed so one I would sell them but
number two then I would support them
yeah and that's really when I started to
understand franchising because really at
that
point they didn't really understand what
I did or they didn't really value what I
did as an air developer and I knew that
at the time and so it wasn't a a a job
where I was getting a lot of thanks it
wasn't a business where I was getting a
lot of thanks uh from them but I also
knew that I was giving them a ton of
value and when I ended up selling that
area development I would get all kinds
of emails from them Eric we never
realize how much support you gave we
never realize how much you did and um
and then I just realized like I want to
be a part of Brands franchises that
offer a lot of support and a lot of help
to their franchises what did it cost for
you to get an area development deals is
it basically you just have to hit a
certain Mark of in development as far as
the amount of of franchises you're
putting up did you have to purchase the
rights for the area how how does that
deal work yeah so at the time I think
the prices have gone way up since then
and it was really expensive for us at
the time so what year is this roughly
this was in the early 2000s okay and the
way they priced these back then I think
they still do it today is either by
territory or by population and it was in
the hundreds of thousands is when we is
what we paid for that and what you're
really doing is you are it's a super
passive business because you are you get
them up and going and then once somebody
knows how to run the business you don't
have to do a whole lot of coaching at
that time because when they open up
their second location they don't need
you as much and when they open up their
third location they really don't need
you and you had people doing second and
third locations not just the ones and
what did it cost to you know at that
time if you know you came to me and I'm
in Austin and U saying okay you got me
interested in wanting to uh buy one of
these franchises what would it cost for
me to get in business the franchise fee
was about 40,000 at that time so they
would come up with 40,000 and then it
wasn't that much more it was around the
$100,000 Mark to get started because we
weren't going into high-end real estate
it was it was uh small square footage
not in the best of centers not in the
best parts of town and so landlords
weren't asking premiums for those
location so it was a really inexpensive
business to get going so at a point in
time you decided okay we've got 42 of
these things you own this basically you
own the development deal and you get
cash flow from each of the I guess they
they give you an override uh so is it
the franchisee that was paying you the
franchise or or both the franchisee was
paying me but they were paying the
franchise or the royalty so let's say
there was $100,000 of royalties that
were paid $50,000 would come back to me
so the franchisee would pay the
franchisor and the franchisor would then
pay me okay so yeah so the franchisor
was basically paying you out of their
proceeds for the development deal I see
and then uh and you also had
transferable rights meaning you can sell
your position there which is what you
ended up doing yeah and a lot of times
when you have an area development like
that it's the corporate office it's the
parent company the parent franchise or
that buys it back from you because as an
area developer you were the massage MBI
did area developments and there's a
there's a number of different franchise
ores that use that as a growth model
because we paid the franchise or money
when they didn't have a lot of money
typically when they're get just getting
started they didn't have to pay for the
operational team I was the operational
team they didn't have to pay for someone
to sell franchises because I did that
and so it was a win for them early on
cash injection free labor but on the
back end is when it was a win for me
because then they wanted to purchase
back that cash flow so they bought it so
it was the franchise or that bought you
out correct that's great so then what
was your next move so now you say wow
okay um suddenly I'm rich yeah I'm rich
at least I thought I was at the time and
uh and so I was wondering what was next
for me and I knew about this thing
called franchise Consulting and I knew
that there was a company out there that
helped people buy franchises I didn't
know what they should do and and I knew
about franchises so I didn't need
educated on that I needed deal flow I
wanted to see and hear from the
franchise Wars what was going on on the
inside of these organizations because I
had insight into Liberty Tax like that
nobody else had right because I was on
the inside so I wanted to get on the
inside of some of these other ones that
I didn't know a lot about and so I
started to help people find franchises
and I did it because I wanted to help
myself find my next brand so I found my
next brand and then I had friends you
know calling me up and saying what are
you doing Eric because other people were
starting to exit at that time and then
that's when I found my next one it was
an area development in a home care a
senior care business and I ended up
purchasing that so you got an area
development deal from them what was the
name of that franchise Synergy Home Care
okay so Synergy Home Care and so
basically were you researching the
market and then saying that that's where
I'm going now and so what was it that
attracted you about that it was the
Aging population the demographic and and
I was not finding very many air
development opportunities out there they
get less and less every year right and I
wanted to find another air development
because I had such great success with
the first one right and that was aging
population great demographic and I did
not have to own a location myself and I
could do what I already learned at
Liberty Tax and just do do it with a
different brand why should somebody look
at franchising as a potential way to
build wealth franchising is an easier
way to own a business in my opinion you
can as a franchisee you buy into a
system and it's a system of doing
business it's the trial and err has been
taken out of it you as a new business
owner that you don't have experience
hiring you don't have experience
marketing you don't have experience in
opening up a first location or finding
customers or doing all the kinds of
things that you would have to research
or pay a consultant or hire expensive
people to do for you you buy into that
system and they are your business
partner and they've done it and not only
them one of the greatest things about
franchising is all the franchisees so if
you get into a system that has a number
of franchisees that have gone through
the trial on air in addition to the
parent company doing that you get to
learn from all their mistakes right and
I remember one of the first first big
cost savings that I had as a franchisee
when I realized like I am so glad I'm a
part of this company we were spending a
lot of money um over a million dollars
in a buildout to open up uh soless Salon
Studios and the parent company Sola the
founders of that noticed something with
the building and said you guys should
look at taking care of this and having
this addressed before you actually start
and um and it saved us you know a ton of
money by just having that one thing and
the landlord ended up paying for it
where we didn't have to and and I
realized like I thought that just right
there paid for a lot of those franchise
fees that I had incured already right so
it's it's a safer bet you know because a
lot of times entrepreneurs get excited
saying hey I'm going to I want to open
up a you know elderly care or whatever
it might be I may a CPM going up a tax
shot but saying H might be better off if
there's a full business system set up
full brand you know that's done and uh
you know because a lot of people say
well why would I give up my royalties
why would I I think the people who would
say that type of thing never started a
business from scratch for sure and even
to your point of like CPA starting a tax
business they know taxes and so why
don't they start we didn't want CPAs
like if there was a CPA that wanted to
open up at Austin Texas that was a big
red flag because we wanted marketers we
wanted people that were aggressive we
wanted people that could get customers
because you could pay someone to do the
taxes and a lot of people that I talk to
that are looking at buying a franchise
they think they know what they want but
when you ask them a number of questions
that just probe deeper and deeper they
what they really want is something else
is there much franchise opportunity
right now for uh solopreneurs I mean I
know that like in big ways private
Equity money has moved into the
franchise world you know that you know
sometimes you got uh like I know plan of
fitness is for example you know you they
got private Equity companies buying up
you know dozens of these things and
managing and controlling and you know
they have their own business systems to
put into these Business Systems to you
know I I'm sure things like McDonald's
are owned by a lot of PE companies you
know so these big franchises are like
that are there still opportunities for
you know somebody to say um hey you know
I've got a certain amount of money in an
IRA or you know I'm looking down the
road through my retirement and I think
there's a strong argument that uh you
know rather than me having money sitting
in a market and hoping there's return
buy a cash flowing business and let that
let me live off of that what so what's
your view on all of that yeah I think a
lot of people put their trust in the
market they have this this 401k and
that's their safety net and that's where
they want to build wealth and then you
have this other group that sees that and
they look at their 401k and they're like
I want to use that money and have
combined with my own efforts and build
something and I see people more and more
doing that they're using their 41k
they're using their retirement and
they're taking control of their Destiny
and there are there's a lot of franchise
opportunities for people like that
especially if they're coming out of
retire or before they retire and and
they can buy a business where it's more
semi absentee and I work with a lot of
semi absentee franchisors and I help a
lot of semi- absentee franchises because
I'm one of those I live in a small town
and that's you know it's not in a big
market so all my businesses that I own
are out of State and so I love helping
people that are that want to be that
solopreneur that just want something
instead of just having their money earn
interest for them find a business that
allows them to do that are you uh still
in the elderly care uh space I ended up
selling that back to the franchise or
and I remember so history repeated
itself in a sense youed it yep I
developed it and sold it back and then I
was on to my next one and this is the
one I had just recently had had a larger
exit on and I met the founders again
with this group that I'm a part of where
I help people find franchises I knew the
founders of this company it's called
soless Salon Studios I knew that they
were going to be at this meeting and I
cornered them at the bar before
everything started and I was real
strategic with that and I just kept
buying them drinks and people tend to
get more honest when they're having some
drinks and I was just asking them
question after question after question
and then I was texting my future
business partners this is what I'm
hearing and then they would text me
another question and I would ask them
and buy them another drink and um and
then they were in the mobile home park
business before that and they sold that
and that went into a Reit and so then
they started up this Salon company it's
called Solo Salon Studios and what that
business is is you take about well we
would take about 7,000 square fet of
retail space and we would put about a
million dollars into that facility and
we're left with about 40 individual
Suites that uh we would lease out to
Salon professionals hair stylist
estheticians massage therapists and so
back in uh at the bar uh I realized I
wanted to put this partnership group
together and we wanted to buy an entire
County and so we targeted Orange County
California because this franchise or had
not sold it yet and I knew that it was
just going to be a big a big one it was
going to uh sell a lot of franchises in
a in a short period of time and and in
the past I saw good brands sell out
quickly and I knew I could open up a
couple of them myself and I knew with
the partnership group I could open up a
lot of them myself and negotiate a
better deal and lock up a larger
territory and that's exactly what we did
and so over a 5year period we built 12
Solo Salon studios in Orange County and
really pushed out a lot of the
competition because they saw us growing
so fast we were first to Market and they
stayed away uh for the most part and um
about 5 years later there was another
opportunity to exit so you had the
master development deal on that
particular one plus you your partnership
did they also put up franchises that you
owned in that you know in that deal so
this was the first one that I was not a
master developer on I was not an air
developer I was a franchisee and we
secured the rights to block everybody
else out so we could develop or County
unencumbered that was our Market 12
stores it was actually we purchased the
right to 12 stores and then they wanted
to put more stores in there and that's
when we knew we didn't want to keep
developing and we didn't want them
coming in or competition coming in and
we had a choice to make that's when you
sold it yeah now did the franchisor buy
them or somebody else bought them that's
another interesting one it was Private
Equity that bought that one so that was
my first time dealing with private
equity and that the dealing with that
process it's a long process you know
much longer than the other ones and it
was the private Equity company that
ended up buying the parent company Sola
oh really so they sold too so they sold
too we were the first ones we were the
only ones to get acquired during that
process but we but was great about that
we were an attractive Market we had 12
stores and there was Room to Grow many
more stores in that market and so they
saw there was a lot of Runway there's a
lot of white space in that market and um
and so we took advantage of that and and
we exited was uh the business model
there that it was rental income
basically that you you're B you're
you're getting leases where you can
subdivide and then you can rent
individual things is as or where was the
revenue generated the revenue is exactly
generated that way we would we had 40
individual Suites and we would lease
those out to Salon professionals under
one to twoe contracts and we would
charge them every week than that
business they're used to that and that's
what's interesting so many people they
see a business and they think the
business is something like I would tell
people I'm in the salon business because
I didn't want to get into everything and
explain it to them my daughters thought
I was in the salon business and they
thought I knew how to cut hair and do
all of that stuff and um they thought it
was pretty cool at the time U but I was
in the real estate business so in in my
mind I was in the real estate business
and and then that's really when I
started to experience extreme semi
absentee ownership we had 12 locations
um over $12 million invested into them
and we had about five fulltime people
working for us we had our director of
operations and then we had two to three
leasing agents and then at any time we
had one admin person and a person that
was doing all of the fixing of stuff and
the franchisee was responsible for the
marketing uh for the most part uh so
which was used so I imagine had a
marketing some marketing people on hand
to to promote the place we are marketing
people that they were the face of the
business and they were the people
helping they were uh boots on the ground
giving tours and they were also doing
the marketing so there wasn't a whole
lot of marketing to that business it
really marketed itself because in that
business you had hair stylists who hate
where they work and they have a book of
business and they're so afraid to to
move out cuz in that business
a hair stylist that's working for
somebody if that somebody gets win that
this hair stylist is moving to a
different business their stuff will be
out on by the front door right and
they're and they're gone and so it's a
really interesting business we had to um
be really careful in how we approach
them because they were so afraid to come
in and even look around um so there
wasn't a whole lot of marketing that we
had to do and they were they were ready
to start making more money themselves
they wanted a simple easy way to make
money and we provided that solution
their other option is to continue
working where they are which is full of
drama and they absolutely hated it or to
go find uh their own space build it out
lease it up sign a long-term commitment
a long-term guarantee and they didn't
want to do it nor probably had the
resources to even if they wanted to
that's their that's what they enjoy they
enjoy interacting with people and and
doing their service they don't enjoy
running a business so like everything
else it seems that good franchises are
soling some sort of a problem you know
like you're just you're just literally
describing the plight of a aesthetician
or you know a hairstylist and operator
some variety uh where either they are in
an environment that is untenable and uh
or they try to go out on their own which
is you know very risky and and you know
they're probably not business people
that can do that very well so now you
basically provide you know space so
you're in a subletting business for the
most part and solving a problem for a
large volume of people and of course
there's a lot of customers for that that
in Orange County California 100% yeah
wow so uh you have another move yeah
what's next for me is I'm becoming a
franchisor and I'm helping uh
franchisors become better franchisors
and doing that I have all this
experience as a franchisee I think it's
seven or eight different brands that
I've owned um over the years and so I
have incredible amount of experience as
a franchisee I've helped people buy
thousands of territories and start and
start their locations and what's next
for me is I'm working with my business
partner bados kouan who owns fitbody
boot camp and he's an incredible man at
masterminds and I'm a huge believer in
masterminds and so the two of us are
helping
franchisors be better and basically
learn from us bados as a franchisor
who's made mistakes myself who has sold
thousands of franchises over my career
and help them avoid a bunch of mistakes
themselves and then myself and two
that's Consulting basically and that's
that part of it and then you're going to
actually put up franchises or be a
franchisor yourself yeah with bados and
I it's a franchise ignition Mastermind
okay and we're Consulting with
franchisors and then the second thing
that I'm put in a lot of time and focus
and attention um in is a franchise or
and I have the two other business
partners in that and we are going uh
away from everything that I've done in
the past with beauty and Fitness and
things like that and going into the
service based business so when you say
service based what kind of service based
business are you considering so we see a
big need in the service-based business
and we see uh private equity and what
they're doing and they like to put
together a number of different
franchises in the service based sector
and um and and put money into them and
so we realize there's a need for
somebody to come in as uh as owners who
are active as a franchise or and that
are not private equity and to help
franchisees in the service-based
business and so an example of that um is
one that's really attractive to us is
Roofing sighting and gutters because we
know that business is you know it's got
its challenges and we also know that
it's a very good business for a lot of
people and as a franchisor we want to go
into businesses where we can where we
can make money as a franchisor but we
want the franchisees to be able to do
well and and we know Roofing is one of
those sectors where they can do that and
so um what we would like to do is
acquire Mom and Pops or young franchise
or that don't have the expertise or they
don't have the knowledge or the capital
to take it from zero or 10 or 20 or 30
units to over a 100 and so we're coming
in and partnering with them or acquiring
a majority stake to do that yeah so this
is very interesting I I've actually was
a franchiser in my past life some years
ago so I been through that whole Pro
what is to get those things set up and
and go out and Market etc etc and all
the regulatory side of it too which is
never fun uh but uh so on the other side
of this though somebody's watching us
right now and they're saying okay
franchising is one of the paths I'm
considering for my future um how do I go
out now and figure out what is the right
franchise for me to buy them I'm not
going to go you know have you know a
couple million dollars or you know $5
million to put into you know a franchise
how do I spot a franchise that is
solid you call it established even but
hasn't hit that you know that tipping
point where now it's like you know
ridiculous money to try to get into one
is there you know is there is there a
sweet spot there for me to try to find
and how would I do it it's an
interesting time in franchising right
now because what we were talking about
with all the money being dumped into
franchising through private equity
um and a lot of the data that you get
out there as someone a consumer looking
is through magazines and websites and
and looking at that and a lot of that's
historical data it's really not looking
forward so that's a place where people
start but it but you really don't get
any information that way uh you need to
talk to somebody that knows the inside
of franchising um you need to have
somebody that's knowledgeable but also
cares because it's you don't want to get
to a salesperson right and there's a lot
of people out there that are willing to
sell people that are looking for
franchises because the sales people in
franchising have gotten so good like
they they know the hot buttons they know
the pain points they know all of that
and so you just have to be really
careful on who you're talking to because
things sound really attractive and
reality is not always what it appears so
you need to get with someone that really
knows it and there's Consultants out
there like myself that help people and I
would definitely work with a consult
that because they know things that you
may not know they know what questions
they ask yeah and uh and I guess due
diligence would probably be a good idea
to go to some actual franchises and talk
to the franchises and see if they're
happy and how they a key so really once
you start talking to a consultant the
good ones are going to spend some time
with you and they're going to talk about
their personal experience they're going
to talk about how they've owned and and
the challenges that they've had if it's
all good out there then you're probably
talking to the wrong person but then
let's say you're looking at some Brands
now and a lot of people that I work with
and a lot of my colleagues work with
they come in thinking they want one
thing let's use Subway for an example
they think uh Eric I want a Subway and
and you start asking them why and all
the all the reasons they want that are
safety reasons because there's they see
the customers they're customer and they
see it's a value product and you know
it's a big name and that's why they want
it what they don't think about is
employee turnover like they you know you
ask them how if they're okay with high
employee turnover and what that really
looks like in that type of industry and
that scares them to death and that one
question that that scares them from from
most food Concepts and especially
something like subway where there's High
turnover and then you start really
finding what they what they want and
it's and it is not Subway but it's
something more stable it's something
that they maybe can share they can have
their family come into and do some of
the work or it gives them the lifestyle
that they want at the end of the day
most people come to me and they want
something lifestyle oriented the widget
doesn't matter the service doesn't
matter but it's the lifestyle that that
business can create for them and
everybody's different with what level of
lifestyle that is is it reasonable for
somebody to say um I just want to do one
you know in other words I just want one
cash flowing franchise that you know or
is that like really the only way to to
make real money here is to have multiple
franchises some people can only afford
one franchise and if that's the case
they should only buy one franchise
there's franchise oras that would sell
them three franchises but they really
should only buy one and that's their
stepping stone that was Liberty Tax for
me I couldn't have purchased a Solo
salon at that time and that was a
stepping stone and so a lot of people
just have to adjust their expectations
before they get into it um so they can
see it as a stepping stone and then get
into multi-unit ownership but multi-unit
ownership to me that's where everybody
should be looking and in my opinion you
know it should be about three locations
and that's kind of The Sweet Spot more
than that you probably taking on a
little bit more risk than you should
unless you have really you know big risk
tolerance or high risk tolerance less
than that there you don't really get to
take advantages of economies of scale
and so for myself I'm opening up some Lo
locations in Denver of a company called
Yoga 6 and I have multiple locations
that I'm Yoga 6 so it's a yoga franchise
it's a yoga franchise so it's called
Yoga 6 and I went into that with a
business partner of mine he's the
operational partner and I'm more of the
advisor uh Board of advisor partner and
we are going to open up multiple
locations very close to each other and
there's a couple reasons for that one I
want to uh find the best real estate so
if I had one territory I could only find
the best territory in that one search
area if I own three or more then I can
find the best real estate within any
spot within that territory and that's
happened what I thought was the best
Market that I wanted to go into didn't
have the best real estate deal at the
time I went into one of the worst
markets that I thought I wanted to go
into but I got this incredible real
estate deal and so that's where we're
opening up our first location and then I
have two other locations that are
plotted around it and and in addition to
real estate it allows me to hire faster
and build out my management team and
that allows me to have less involvement
in the business because I can have a
director of operations now and I can
have managers in each of those locations
and my manager my first location can
open up my second location and I can you
know grow it that way so Yoga 6 sounds
like a a newer franchisees I've never
seen it never heard of it so what's a
franchise fee for a Yoga 6 right now so
if I said I might want to go open a yoga
what's the franchise fee so yoga studios
are typically a lot more expensive than
some of the other brands that I've owned
like a Liberty Tax or less expensive
than a Sola but a lot more expensive
than a Liberty Tax and and at first you
don't realize it you don't you think
just because you're open up a yoga
studio it's not going to be that
expensive but then you realize you have
to demo the whole place and then you
have to buy nice stuff to going there
and the real expense in yoga It's Hot
Yoga you can't just be normal yoga it
has to be hot yoga and that just
increases the expenses astronomically
because you have to have everything
ready the HVAC system to bring in all of
that hot air quickly and to take it out
quickly and it just drives the cost so
anytime that I'm looking at a franchise
myself um you look at the franchise
Disclosure document we'll get in the
weeds for just a quick second in the
item seven part of this big document
that franchise ORS are required to give
everybody looking there's an item seven
and it list the high and the low end of
what they anticipate that investment to
be right I always look at the high end
and then add on a bit more to that and
that's proven to be true for me in a
number of different franchises that I've
opened and um I'm expecting the same
thing with Yoga 6 as well so I always
love to have those expectations going
into it are franchise fees negotiable in
other words you know if I were to say
okay go ahead and give me the the
franchise circular I'm going to read
through it that's going to have you tell
me what the fees are Etc um if should I
be like if you were Consulting with me
should I be going back uh to the
franchise or and say um uh I'd like to
pay less for this or make a counter
offer or are they usually pretty much
what they are what they are everybody
likes to negotiate right yeah and and
and including myself and and I I try
every every time I get into a new brand
I try to negotiate something but I think
the Best Brands don't negotiate at all
and to be able to to take that position
of not negotiating you have to have a
good contract a good disclosure document
good franchise agreements when I say
good it's they're always weighted
towards the franchise or but it has to
be fair enough that the majority of
people wanting to buy will buy and if
it's if it's too strong too weighted
towards the franchise ore then they do
negotiate and I know franchise ORS that
do negotiate they'll negotiate territory
size they'll negotiate um different
types of things and they have to put
that in writing they might have to
disclose it to everybody else and they
might not have to disclose it to
everybody else but the best franchise
ores they don't change it for anybody
and what I like about that as a
franchisee on the other side of it is
knowing that you as my neighbor
franchisee got the same thing that I got
I agree so much with that it's like you
know you know did I was I a sucker you
know you know cuz I just accepted a deal
but will they actually charge more money
for a franchise based on ter like an
area that it's in saying well this is a
more valuable area so we pric this one
up here this is less valuable area we
price it lower or are they usually just
standardized no matter where they are
I've seen franchise ores do change the
pricing schedule the price of a
territory um we did it at Liberty Tax we
had small Market territories where we
didn't think that the area was large
enough as an attractive enough as some
of these other areas and we wanted to
sell them and people wanted to buy them
and so we charged a lower fee for that
and that was all disclosed in the
document sure okay and that would make
sense right I mean it's like real
estates it's worth a little bit more
over here than it is over here so what
do you think the future of franchising
is do you think it's still on a a growth
trajectory in general that there's going
to be more and more franchises coming
into the market place or do you feel
like it's kind of like stabilized uh
what do you think what do you think's
going on with that I think the future of
franchising is really interesting we're
going into some uh changes from a legal
perspective uh that franchisors are
having to report income different ways
and there's just more and more
regulation coming to franchise ores
which is a good thing for some
regulation and some of it is is
cumbersome and will be a challenge but I
think with private Equity money coming
in to the franchise ores they are going
to continue to grow when I look at
emerging Brands there's a lot of
emerging Brands coming up I talk to a
lot of people that are thinking about
franchising and I seen and I've had a
lot of conversations with these Brands
and there's more and more of them so I
think there will be more Brands coming
in the challenge is is getting to that
100 locations it's most franchise ores
never get to 100 locations and you have
to get to scale as a franchise or to be
able to make money and that's what and
that's what I'm saying like boy you know
maybe when I see a franchise or get to
90 92 locations that's the time for to
buy they're not big enough yet where
their prices are going to jump but
they're big enough to say that you know
they look like they're here to stay and
that's that's is that kind of like a
sweet spot you know if I'm making an
investment if I had my perfect scenario
it would be to buy a franchise when that
franchise or had a number of people open
right there's a number of franchises
that I can call and talk to because
that's probably the most important thing
to do and maybe they have a hundred or
or so locations open and so there's
history there's history with just
getting them open there's history with
some of them being being open for a
number of years and there there's
history in different parts of the
country as well because they all perform
differently in different markets so that
would be ideal the challenge today is
like I was saying earlier so many people
are are trying to buy franchises the
salese are so good at selling franchises
that you have to get in early and you
you typically have to make a decision
early on before it's proven as much as
you would like it to be so you have to
take more risk to to do that but if I'm
the
franchisor I don't want my salespeople
selling people who aren't going to win
right because that's going to kill my
franchise pretty quickly but uh but you
know salesperson's commissioned so I
guess they're thinking a little bit more
short term than the franchise or
sometimes well there's a lot of
franchisor that are doing things the
right way and they're growing the right
way and they're not growing too fast
they're growing at a a really good
sustainable amount where they can keep
up with it and there's some franchise or
that have private Equity exit on their
mind and that's not necessarily a bad
thing but I think as someone buying into
a franchise or I want to align with
their Vision I want to align with with
where they're going I know some
franchise ores that they're their
Founders are like they would they do not
want to sell like it's like family this
franchise or I was talking to one the
other day and they said Eric I use a
Thanksgiving test I want I want the any
franchisee that's in my Sy system to be
able to come to my house for
Thanksgiving anytime and us to be able
to enjoy that time together and when I
hear franchise ORS talking like that and
I know franchisees it's one thing to
hear that but then when I talk to their
franchisees and I validate that with
them because I know what's going on
culturally inside of franchises that
means a lot to me there's a lot of
weight that I put on that so I think
those ones that are that have that
culture and I also think it's that moral
compass of the the founder the founders
is really involved they're also focused
so they have that moral compass and
they're focused on the business that's
one that I think has a higher
probability for franchisees Success
because who if they want you to come
over to their house for Thanksgiving
like that's that's their more Compass
that's what they want and so I feel
comfortable going into a brand like that
that has a number of them opened and
it's not just about making sales so now
you got somebody's attention people
watching watching this somebody's
looking saying I'm feeling better and
better about this franch I'm liking this
I like what I'm hearing I like what
Eric's saying um and uh I I feel
enthusiastic not necessarily a whole lot
of confidence that I know how to go and
buy this so so now what's my next step
to try to validate you know uh a
franchise to to go into so when you're
talking to a franchise company you
understand some operations you
understand some financials but if I had
to tell some someone like what is like
the Crux the most important part about
buying a franchise it's talking to
franchises I mean the franchise or can
tell you whatever they want and
sometimes it's like I know from the
inside like what they're getting from
the franchise or is absolutely true and
others you're just like you question
like what are they what are they really
saying does it really line up with what
the franchise e are experiencing so the
way to really understand that as
somebody looking is talking to
franchisees and I see so many people go
about this the wrong way and the wrong
way is how much money are you making
yeah you know how easy is this and you
know are you happy that you did this you
know those are all they're not bad
questions but they have to be put into
context and if I'm from Corporate
America and I'm just going into
franchising and I'm talking to a
franchisee who has three locations open
and they've been open up for 2 years
that person is on Easy Street probably I
mean they they the first one was was
probably a nightmare to open up you know
like it was difficult it was tough it
was like a business to open up and then
they open up their second one it's a lot
easier and then their third one they Pro
for me like every time I've opened up
anytime that I've opened up a third one
like I'm not even there I I I don't even
go to Grand Opening it it happens and
I've been on vacation and I got a note a
text that says hey we just opened up you
know location number three or four or
five or six and I had no idea it was
even opening and so once you get a
number of them open it's easy so if you
as a perspective franchisee calling them
to see like hey how is life is it good
would you do it again and you catch them
at your number three with three
locations open up they're probably on
vacation somewhere life is good but if
you catch someone early on and they are
opening up that first one it's a
completely different story so you have
to have context to who you're talking to
and how much they're like you I see a
lot of people people that uh don't have
experience in in business or hiring and
things like that and they they need to
be talking to people like themselves and
how much support does the franchise or
give in that area and I know franchise
or that give a tremendous amount of
support like you know one of the
franchise Yoga 6 we had the corporate
Team interview a number of our general
managers before we hired them that was
part of the process so they provide a
lot of support in that area and so you
just you have to have context to the
person that you're talking to to see if
they're in the same phase of life and to
see if what is challenging to them would
be challenging to you I've talked to um
corporate people that have high pain
jobs all around America and they're on
the plane all the time and you know
there's you know two different types of
people that are okay some one person
that is making a lot of money that's
flying around the country is okay if
their manager quits and they have to
hire another one somebody else that
would you know they couldn't fly
anywhere they would that would just like
drive them crazy and they wouldn't be
able to make really good decisions so I
see a good franchisee is also a good
decision maker yeah well this has been
more than fascinating and I I could tell
that you uh eat breathe and live this
stuff with enthusiasm so uh really great
uh great overview and profiling on what
it means to be in the franchise business
the various aspects of it how to vet and
you know determine if if a franchise
might be right for you Etc so uh I
definitely appreciate you taking the
time to share all this and I think it's
an area of wealth development that is
critical for people to assess and see if
it's right for them great I've enjoyed
this thank
[Music]
you
next up we have Christina wise founder
of wealthy wealthy with an important
message about the difference between
income and wealth income is money you
make but it's not necessarily wealth
wealth is the control of assets that
make you more money on top and
Christina's model for building a
business that pays you for life
sometimes with just a few hours work
each week is an incredibly powerful way
to bring a wealth breakthrough into your
life take a
look Christina thanks for doing this hey
my pleasure so a lot of people I respect
tell me I have to speak to you so so
here we are saying you got a lot of
wisdom I guess truth and labeling given
your last name is wise uh so uh lot of
wisdom around um preserving wealth
creating it's one thing but preserving
it's another and uh for entrepreneurs I
think that's a a big deal for people who
suddenly find themselves in success uh
uh they don't necessarily find that that
is sustainable um because maybe the
attributes or considerations that got
them there are not the same
considerations for preserving wealth and
I understand that you're the person to
talk to about this yeah so this is my
favorite conversation I just love having
the conversation about money because
it's not a conversation we have at the
dinner table and even in the
entrepreneurial world when we're talking
about this thing called money it's
usually in the context of business or
revenue or how many zeros you have and
we're not talking about money in the
context of Home Finance personal finance
because I believe the way we build
wealth is all through personal finance
not through business finance yet
everything we're talking about is on the
business side of the equation so what I
like to teach is that or share is that
there's these three categories of money
and all of them are different
disciplines and we need to get good at
all three I'd like to know before we get
into the nitty-gritty what caught you on
this how did you end up here wellow
that's a long story well it's funny to
even think that I'm I'm teaching money
or talking about money or even know
anything about it because I started in a
trailer home and I grew up very poor and
I guess because of that from a very
young age I was motivated by money so I
was always looking for ways to make it
and was on my own starting very young
also so I had to figure out ways to make
it in order to buy clothes or to buy
food or to pay for things at school so
necessity is the mother of invention and
when I was young I was always innovating
ways to make money so that's the way I
started and then I got very good I got
into this thing called real estate and
real estate sales so I got really good
at making money but then I found myself
in a situation in my early 30s after I
got really good at making it that I
didn't have any and I found myself in a
lot of debt and a really existential
crisis after getting divorced being a
single mother I was a primary wage
earner so I had to pay child support and
I had to to pay off the debts that I
didn't know we had and I wasn't making
money anymore so I was bumped up against
this crisis of how do I feed my babies
and I was so full of shame because I
wanted to create something different for
my children that how I grew up and here
I was creating the same situation for my
children I couldn't pay the light bills
I was in all this debt I couldn't put
groceries in the refrigerator and it was
only because colleagues at work actually
pitched in to help us furnish the house
and get the utilities turned on and we
couldn't have made it if I didn't
have colleagues at work and peers that
actually helped out so thank God for
them at the same time I was so ashamed
because I here I was having to take
charity again just like I did when I was
a child do you think it was a
self-fulfilling prophecy uh you know
that you this is how you grew up and
somehow you you needed to find your your
way there again into that circumstance
or maybe so maybe there's a universal
lesson in that because there's been
these like these existential crises of
my life and they all seem to be some
sort of wakeup call from my childhood so
probably and that that was that big 2x4
is that but the big lesson that I
learned back then is I was really great
at making it but how come I was so great
at making it but I didn't have any yeah
so that was that first question that I
wanted to go find out and I asked the
question like here I am and like
Financial despair like this existential
crisis I don't know how I'm going to get
myself out of were you still working at
that time I was but the reason I was in
this situation I went through this
divorce and what do divorce people do
they find fight over all the stuff the
attorneys get all the money and you know
many people have been through that
situation so while I was fighting my
divorce that was like my business and my
business wasn't making any money so I
really just got to a place where i' let
my business go I wasn't making money now
I had this debt now I had child support
and yada y y and just a terrible
financial situation and I couldn't go to
my parents and ask for help
so I just had this moment moment of like
okay after I broke down and you know
just breaking apart and went through my
sob story and kind of my victimization
story and said okay well no one's going
to do this for me so I better figure out
this money thing and that's what I did I
just made it a life goal to get good at
money and realized that it wasn't the
answer wasn't making more of it and that
was this first money myth that I came
across is that it's like there's this
belief that the answer to all my money
problems is to just make more money and
I found the more money you make if you
don't understand how money Works money
just causes more problems right so and
you can find yourself in much worse
situations you're literally buying
problems with your money you really are
actually so I just went on this personal
Endeavor to learn about money and I
figured if I learned what rich people
did and I did what rich people did maybe
I could too be rich and so I just went
on a on a discovery to learn about money
and that became my personal Journey did
you find when you started looking
outward and going on this journey that
um your story was not unusual but many
other people who produced wealth ended
up not having it and uh shell shocked
and didn't know why well I bump up
against that all the time in my work
today and that's what especially
entrepreneurs I call it the
entrepreneurial trap because there's
just all this conversation on growth and
scale and big and more and so we get
caught in this trap of what I call the
earn spend trap where we make all this
money and then we spend all our money
then we go make more money then we spend
more of the money and that's just one of
money's operational laws that says
expenses will always rise to match
income so I found myself in this
situation the more money they made the
more money I spent the more money I made
the more money I spent and then it all
came crashing down and sometimes it can
come crashing down from a divorce
sometimes it comes crashing down because
of a health issue which my was my S
second existential crisis sometimes it
comes crashing down because the economy
changes but Mo most of our finances are
House of Cards like it's not set up for
wealth it's set up for income so what's
interesting here is that it sounds like
some of this is maybe informational like
you know understanding things in a
different way how much of it is
psychological a huge piece of
psychological and when I think about
that or talk about that I break money
into these two sides money is has so
many dimensions that's what makes it
fascinating so I love talking about it
and studying about it and and working
with it and growing it sometimes losing
it making it it just there's all these
different parts of that makes it complex
on one hand but it's actually very
simple on the other but it's this blend
of what I call the woooo side like the
money manifestation the magic of money
especially as entrepreneurs we create
money from nothing we have this radical
idea and all of a sudden it turns into
people pay us for it right when it was
in our head or just on a whiteboard at
one period of time so money can be so
magical and there's the mystical side of
it like I said creating something from
nothing but on this woooo or
manifestation side what I call the
Impractical side of money our
relationship to it meaning how we feel
about it our beliefs about it our story
or narratives like what words do we say
to ourselves when we say about money
like oh I can't afford it that's one
thing to say or hey I just choose not to
buy that right now I mean every word we
use About Money Matters our spiritual
connectivity to it like is do we believe
in a flow and abundance of creation and
that everything is possible are we
really stuck in this really scarcity and
and budgeting and holding down and
attached to or fear of loss so on the
magic side of money like anything else
in the vibrational energetic side that a
lot of people teach is that it's love or
fear and it's a love of money or a fear
of money it's a love of the creation or
the fear of failure it's the love of the
abundance and what's possible or the
fear of losing it so that's this magical
dance with money on this more
metaphysical side is there is there a a
guilt around people who want to conclude
uh that they have a love of money rather
than a fear well I think yeah I think
people bump up against that all the time
is if is it if I am I bad or greedy or
something wrong with me if I say I love
money and I believe another one of
money's laws these invisible universal
laws is we have to love our money if
we're going to keep it and have it and
grow it and not love like greed like
take from somebody else or hold on to it
quite the opposite like an abundance of
love and magic and I'm just so grateful
for you and I want to touch you and feel
you and see you and appreciate you for
all the good that you do for me for my
family for others for this ripple effect
that can go out so it's just it's with
anything it's when we can adjust the
mindset and get rid of some of the old
narratives or beliefs or things that
we've just culturally been indoctrinated
with or from our family we can just
break those down disc deconstruct them
and replace them with more powerful
narrative that's more about love and
abundance on the magical side of money
the metaphysical side so what were some
of the the pivotal moments then so you
went on this journey you had to go
figure this out uh what did you what did
you find well the beginning was I just
need to go learn about it so it's less
about the metaphysical side at that
point and more about the Practical and
that was just getting good at business
and understanding business but then it
was understanding business is just one
set of books right and business is about
money and it's entrepreneurs and that's
what we do we're and it's all about this
thing called profit at the end of the
day and so the better we are at business
the better we are at making profit but
where it tends to break down is that
where we are business is different than
our personal balance sheet so what I
teach is a concept that our personal
life like our household it's our real
business so when we start thinking
practically that our household is our
business and not our business is our
business then we start operating our
household as the wealth building
business our business is just the income
generating business and our household's
the wealth building business because
there's a radical difference between
income and wealth and so when we think
we're the CFO of our own household and
profit first is the concept we're
looking in our household then we're
looking at creating taking a portion
we're taking our profit from our
business we're moving it to our
household business we're taking profit
first that we're going to move over to
invest to build our net worth and we're
going to live and save off the rest of
it so that's an operational system
basically but it's how we operate and
how we manage and master our money
practically so that we have money to
invest that's different that's a
different class of assets than our
business asset so creating that
separation um how difficult is it for
someone to uh move from the frame of
reference that uh you know my wealth is
built in my company versus what you're
describing it's usually it's not obvious
and that's the problem especially since
everything we're talked about is just go
make more money and again that's our
make more money I spend more money so I
see a lot of entrepreneurs books that
make a high income but they have no net
worth and what that means is that and
they come to me in secret and say
because they're on stage and they're
saying hey I've got a eight fig business
and they're teaching the world how
they've done so well on the revenue side
right and I'm saying one I don't care
how much revenue you make I want to know
how much profit you make I mean that's
the truth teller is the profit side
right but even that what they're doing
is even if they're doing good on the
profit side and have lots of zeros on
their annual income they're coming to me
in confidence and saying Christina I'm
tired I'm burnt out I'm just tired of
making my $100,000 a month payroll and I
can't really take a vac and my business
owns me and I'm just what do I do and
their business is doing great but
they're still trapped in their business
meaning they're really handcuffed to it
they cannot walk away it's not a
sellable asset the way it's been built
it's been more of a cash flow I was just
about to say to sometimes they
rationalize that uh well the value of my
business is where all of my Equity or
you know where my net worth is if I if I
have an eight figure business um it's
it's got a $10 million value and if you
go to my balance sheet you know I own
the shares that business that's what
makes my balance sheet look great but uh
but you're discovering that um that's
merely more of a fantasy it's more of a
fantasy and it's not predesigned or
pre-thought so there's really just two
exit
strategies let's say if we're going to
exit for whatever the exit day is and
and so when we're looking at our
business as an exit strategy we have to
go in with that strategy at M in mind so
we're going in with the whole strategy
of how we're going to build the
valuation of the company where we're not
the biggest part of the value of that
company and it's an operational system
on its own and so we're position it
we're growing it position it for an exit
at some point but even then what do you
do with your money when you exit it but
that's but that's one exit Strate
strategy so that's that type of the
business strategy there is I'm building
an asset that I'm going to sell and the
exit of that business hopefully will be
enough money that will suffice and be
what can sit on my balance sheet later
on so nothing matters on the balance
sheet when we have it because unless we
sell it or unless it's cash flowing it's
money that's not real not liquid it's
not liquid so the other thing when it
comes to business is that there's that
is building as an asset or a business
can just be a cash flow machine so when
it's a it's a lifestyle business or cash
flow it means we're never really setting
up to sell it we didn't really go in
that mind if we do or if we sell it then
maybe that's gravy but what that means
is that we're taking a portion of the
cash flow when we move it to our
household business and we're taking a
portion of the cash flow and we're
building our balance sheet when look at
our balance sheet we don't want the
whole valuation of the business to be on
there because the likelihood that we're
going to sell it or sell it for enough
is probably going to be pretty slim if
we didn't go in with that strategy in
the first place full sense of security
basically thinking you know I'm worth
all this money but not really so what
role do you play in all this you know
you you've got this understanding now uh
born out of your own personal pain if
you will um now you're going and you're
servicing other entrepreneurs trying to
get them to uh to shift in their ways uh
to create real wealth personal wealth um
so what role do you play in helping them
do that my role is really is an educator
trainer coach and an adviser in a
certain capacity but I don't sell
anything I just teach I teach mindset I
teach Frameworks I teach systems and
methodologies for how to do this to get
out of the income game and get in the
net worth game and in the in the money
game there are certain questions to be
asked like money like I said it's it's
it's the metaphysical side but it's the
Practical side and from my what from my
view I see people that are authors or or
speakers and are really just talking on
the manifestation side you know the the
Law of Attraction and you just get the
right mindset and all the money is going
to drop in your bank account on the
other side it's really black and white
it's the CPA the tax strategists the
financial advisors like what stocks do
you pick really just on the Practical
side on the on the investing practical
side and the magic is blending these two
together and I see it's it's really a
blend of both because I work again with
a lot of high income entrepreneurs but
they self-sabotage they spend all their
money or they blow out they take huge
risks where it's still all gone which
has a lot to do with our self-worth
equation our value and our selfworth has
a lot connected to the value that we
want to place on our balance sheet so
again it's just blending these two
pieces together and philosophically
where are we grounded because we're in
this cultural philosoph this
philosophical cultural soup if you will
this consumerism and status and so the
more money we make the more status we
buy the more money we make the more
stuff we have to hold up that status and
we get trapped there versus maybe living
or creating different philosophical
doctrines that we can rest in that keeps
it more of an internal game an internal
reward versus an external reward but in
this philosophical piece everything's
life designed so in the money part of
the thing when we get stuck in business
and we get stuck in spending everything
we make when I ask people like how much
money is enough very few people have an
answer and if I say how much money is
enough they say I don't know but more
than I'm making now or more than I have
now and the truth is is that if we're
really going to win at this money game
there's a number where we know it's
enough what do you mean by enough so
that's so yeah so what is the what does
wealth mean so if we say I have wealth
or or I'm rich what's a definition for
that and the thing is it's different for
a lot of different people and sometimes
they make it metaphysical like wealth is
what you have left over when everything
else is gone uh others like wealth is I
have a certain net worth number and so I
like to put oh and there's this concept
called retirement which is such
right so that people are still talking
about retirement is fascinating to me
especially to entrepreneurs especially
to entrepreneurs but it's the idea of
freedom
and so to me what I'm looking at is
freedom and in the money world we call
it Financial Freedom there are other
types of freedoms there's political
Freedom there's there's uh space Freedom
time freedom but in the world of
Financial Freedom Financial Freedom and
to me wealth and number is is how much
is enough to live the good life that you
want which is both a philosop
philosophical and practical question so
philosophically how much does it what is
a good life to you right and and I guess
is that um so if somebody's now watching
it saying okay I want to answer that
question um and you're right I think
everybody's got their own point of view
this becomes you know very much a
philosophical and even psychological
question right so uh but if I were you
know saying are you saying if I what's
enough meaning that I don't have to work
anymore what's enough meaning that I
feel like I can sleep at night without
worry I mean I could think of 10 ways
that I might want to answer that
question yeah and you get to answer it
any of the 10 ways if we're after the
freedom and Financial Freedom then we
have to look at the we have to look at
distinctions or definitions so what
would be a definition for Financial
Freedom and my definition for Financial
Freedom means the cash flow from my
assets nonworking income or true passive
income I said don't go over that too
fast because when when you're talking
about assets you're saying that this is
these are assets that produce income
that you don't have to get up and make
happen every day nonworking income so
there's only two types of income working
income and non-working income working
income or passive income not passive
income that's a funnel in our business
but passive income means the assets are
produced in the cash flow not my body
not my hard work meaning a couple
examples of people that we talk about
yeah so let's say if I have a certain
real estate portfolio on my asset side
and it makes me
$250,000 a year and let's just pretend
making up a number the cost of living a
good life is $250,000 a year I don't
have to go to work right so that's
Financial Freedom so plug it in 100,000
250 2 million 10 million and everybody
has their number what that is is that
with everything there's tradeoffs so I
have no aspiration to be a billionaire
because I don't want the tradeoff of
what it would take for me to AC you know
acquire that or build that assuming I
would be capable of the first place so
everybody's numbers are different
because what are they willing to trade
to hit that number but again what's a
great life lifestyle for you might be a
different lifestyle for me so it's
looking at what is a good life in these
different categories of life and
answering that question and then
quantifying it how much does it cost and
it actually cost a lot less to live when
we have when we don't have a mortgage we
don't have car payments we don't have
credit card payments we don't have
student loan payments so when we have
zero personal debth and we just live a
good life it's it's really remarkable
how much we complicate our lives by all
these big payments and all these
different things nothing fundamentally
wrong with that love nice things but
when we really get clear on our number
we realize that we can probably get to
that number much quicker than we thought
we could actually live a really good
life if we hit that number and if we
want to blow it out from there let's go
I mean it's not like good enough like
status quo and I'm never going to work
again but I call that number that's the
freedom number because then I get to
choose whether I go to work I it's the
freedom of what to do who to do it with
and when to do it so you get your time
and space back and you get more options
and choices is the hardest part for you
uh when working with a do you call them
clients yes okay so when you're working
with a client is the hardest part for
you getting them to actually conclude on
those things or is it getting them to
implement or is it equally as hard it's
equally as hard conceptually they get
there pretty quickly once I break it out
and just say okay there's these three
categories of money there's your
business the earning there's your
household and then there's your
investing there are three different
things so the what we're the when we're
in our business and building our
business we're in business that's
different than investing when we're a c
when we're in our household we're living
our lifestyle we're paying our bills and
a portion of that's going to buy assets
or build our balance sheet on our
balance sheet our business should
probably just be one small piece of the
pie chart but we have to understand we
need to build out that balance sheet in
a diversified manner not Diversified
like stocks and bonds but Diversified is
how much of our balance sheet is our
business how much of our balance sheet
is protection how much the balance sheet
is liquid assets how much of the balance
sheet is cash flow assets how much the
balance sheet is growth assets how much
of the balance sheet is our health
because our health is wealth and how are
we taking care of so it's everything
we're investing in but even with our
entrepreneurs I see entrepreneurs is
that they make money they either spend
it all or they keep all their money back
in put it in the business so they're
just constantly in this churn of putting
it back putting it back and so what I
like entrepreneurs to do is make your
money pay yourself take take your
portion off the first buy put it over in
your saving money that you're going to
invest so then anytime if you have let's
say I don't know $100,000 that you have
in your investment bucket in your
investment waiting there that you've
saved willing to invest then as an
entrepreneur you could
say maybe I'm a little overleveraged my
own business right now maybe I should
put this under 100 Grand in a different
type of asset or maybe I want to put a
portion of that and reinvest and
capitalize some of my business and put
the you know put the rest of it more so
my portfolio is a little bit more
balanced and diversified versus just
keep thinking just put it back in the
business put it back in the put it back
in the business which is very risky so
to answer your question you know when I
teach these things and break it apart
conceptually it's like that makes a lot
of sense I can do that now the problem
with anything is even if we understand
conceptually changing habits changing
lifestyle doing trade-offs and expenses
and doing different things in order to
be able to do that tends to be the hard
part
so did you fix this in your own world
before you went out to do it in others
in other words you went out you went on
the search um and you basically said
okay I've had this existential crisis um
you know something's wrong I made a
bunch of money where is it uh you came
back did you get back into real estate
what did you do I did I I mean I I went
on the study for money and business and
everything that I teach now I never
thought I would share with another
person it was never my ambition to teach
money or I in 2012 if you hadd said
you're going to be a financial
bestselling Financial author you're
going to have thousands of clients
you're going to be speaking you're going
to be doing these types of interviews on
money i' feel like that is the craziest
thing I've ever heard in my life I'm in
real estate I have real estate
businesses and real estate technology
businesses and I'm an entrepreneur and
all these different things but see in
2013 I got sick MH and had a Health
crisis that was my second 2x4 and I'm
lucky to be here and nearly died and but
it was one of those Universal lessons
again because here I was good at money
in business and now I'm on my deathbed
and what I realized in that during that
horrific experience and going through
that darkness and going through all my
money again because it at the time it
cost me a quarter million dollars cash
just to save my life W so one thing like
money is so important I came up with
this like this Paradox is money's more
money really is more important than
anything in my case it saved my life I
wouldn't be here hadn't I not been a
good Steward of money and practi you
know put into practice the things I'd
learned from my mentors and gurus and
authors and and all the work and
masterminds all the work that I did to
to put everything into place so I had
cash I had assets uh my that business
those businesses started break down
because I was sick and not in them so
here I am in a very similar situation
but the point is is that thank God I had
the money on the other hand when I was
on my deathbed I didn't get give a rat's
ass about my Range Rover my Lakehouse my
primary residence all those achievements
on my wall all the accolades all the
jewelry like everything that I had now
granted it was all paid for in cash and
you know it was nice but I didn't care
about any of it when I was sick what did
I want when I was sick yeah your I
wanted my health back like wouldn't
Steve Jobs probably pay put I don't know
spend his last billionth dollar if he
would have gotten more time so that was
a big wakeup call is that we spend so
much of our time our energy we trade our
health for wealth to get there to be in
this achievement game this success game
this more game and I was in it and I was
winning I was ringing the bell at each
top that I got to but for what I really
I was in a situation like oh my God I
missed my entire life because I was in
this achievement game and the money game
and the business game because at that
point I had no spiritual connectivity
the magic side of money was all about
business achievement and success as the
reward was there a connection between
your business life at that point and
your health absolutely abolutely I mean
it just was not sustainable I mean
everything was push and everything was
go and everything was fast and
everything was squeeze more in and I you
know I had lots of red flags popping up
but I was too busy to notice that I was
sick and I actually thought I was
healthy but even on you know the you
know proverbial literal deathbed it was
like I missed my whole life and I was
chasing something that you can't get and
so much life is just these relationships
and love and and being present and
enjoying things and playing and having
purpose and not about the there and
achievement thing so I was really sad I
here I am now confronting shame and
guilt and sadness and regret that I'd
miss my entire life and so that this was
this big W big wakeup call is Money
Matters more than anything but it's not
about the money if it's not about the
money what is it about and it just
brought this whole purpose to money and
now money serves a very different
purpose for me now than it did then and
it's just underwriting the cost of
living a good life and being able to use
money as a as a means to live my purpose
and to share my purpose so coming out of
that experience actually walked away
completely pivoted out of my old life
and I learned so many lessons and I made
a deal with Mother you that said if I
get another chance I'll teach what I've
learned and so here I am and I like I
said I would never imagine I'd be
teaching this but now it's my it really
is my purpose I believe that everything
I've learned is so that I can help
others and I just teach what I do and
lessons that I've learned so let's put
it on the ground for a minute all right
so I just signed up to become your
client M what's your process like what
do you actually walk through step one
step two step three yeah Step One is
conceptually breaking this up into three
categories earnings category spending
category investing category so B you're
going to come in and review all my we're
going to review all your stuff and we're
going to chip away at some old mindset
we're going to look at where the mindset
Li limitations are your beliefs the
words you use the narratives all the all
those pieces on the the mindset piece is
that a struggle with with especially
with entrepreneurs like you said you
know they've got a certain mask on maybe
around this whole thing and then they
have to show it to you and maybe they
want to convince you how well they're
doing but you know it's time to like
actually have a honest conversation most
of the people by the time they're
they've come to me they've either heard
me say something that's been a wakeup
call or they're bumping up against
something that's not working they're
like at this point they're just like
help me you know what I've been doing is
not working and I know I need the help
and I'm ready so you so you review those
three areas in their life and then once
you done that assessment taken a look at
it then what's your next yes the next is
to help them set up their personal life
their personal financial life like a
business and so really it's the same
thing like everything you're doing here
in business because most of my clients
are business owners and entrepreneurs we
want to do the same things and we're
looking for profit and we're paying
ourselves profit first so we have to
look at where all of your money is going
now the hard thing about that is my high
income entrepreneurs like I don't want
to do this I just want to go make more
money I can just go make more money it's
like but that's the Trap because you
don't want to be trapped we always have
to go make that next dollar or a million
stll or whatever it is and that's the
compulsion right is because you said
this earlier and I think I think it's
100% right is that um okay so i' I've
grown to a certain level now I've lifted
my lifestyle to kind of reflect as
compared to keeping a margin in there
and uh and the entrepreneur what makes
them entrepreneurs is the fact that I
could always do more I could always make
more uh but you have to sort of um
reframe them that's the re that is the
reframe and it's it's to bring forth
money laws like expenses will always
rise to match income that's the expense
crave and that once what what was once a
luxury becomes a necessity meaning it's
really hard to go down in lifestyle when
money changes so when we build these
things in but we're looking at the books
we're looking at how all the money is
spent and we're reorganizing it and I
teach a five-part system for how to
organize your money so that we make sure
that all the different types of money
there's five different monies types of
money that are in our personal business
so we need to earmark and make sure that
our monies are organized that way and
then once we do that and there's certain
portion that money now is going to be
towards Investments if we're spending
that 20% we're going to have to find
that 20% somewhere right and so now
we're going to start moving some money
so we make sure we have money for
investing and we have money for cash and
savings and now we move to the balance
sheet side and we talk about okay right
now we don't really have anything on the
balance sheet because your personal home
doesn't count on your balance sheet even
though it's on there and all these other
things that are on there your business
probably really isn't part of your
balance sheet so now what we need to
talk about is what I call balance sheet
thinking and how we start to build that
out according to model so I have a model
to teach people a model and framework
for how to do this in your household and
then the model that we want to start
building towards to start to build the
balance sheet and what is the balance
sheet it's not about net worth it's not
about acquisition or accumulation or
hitting a number it's all about cash
flow so at the end of the day it's how
are we going to build out our net worth
or our balance sheet in a way with
assets to produce income that will'll
pay for the cost of our lifestyle so
that we have our freedom that at that
point we have the choice as to whether
or not we go to work or maybe it's like
all right been there done that now I can
do something else because my lifestyle
is paid for typical time frame that put
the structure in place going from zero
to saying okay they've made the
transformation into your
model well I teach all this in a in an
8-week like breakdown and then but the
thing is is once you have your system in
place once your mindset is shifted once
you have your system in place you have a
plan in place now we have a lifestyle
now we're just doing this every single
day and it's like exercise or eating
right and there's these three categories
of life that we don't have an option to
opt out of one is the money game money
affects every key area of our life so
and it's a skill set it's a
knowledge-based applied knowledge skill
set so means we have to learn it we have
to good at it get good at it we apply it
over time and over time we get better at
it the second one's our health if we IGN
our health and we don't abide by the
Universal Health laws we're going to
probably bump into a Health crisis if we
don't obey money laws we're going to
bump into a financial crisis and then
the last category is the love category
and that's really like what is the
purpose and what is a good life isn't it
to be present and spend time with people
that we love and develop really great
relationships and and have amazing
experiences and be able to build a
legacy or or multi-generational wealth
or whatever we can do on this other side
that has meaning Beyond just our ability
to do great business and so when we know
our purpose and we're building towards
these things then it just really brings
like I said this different
intentionality to to money understanding
that money for the sake of money doesn't
have any spirituality or doesn't have
any juice to it it's just more money but
when we understand money is for the sake
of lots of love and space and time that
we get in experiences and a certain
portion of that allows us to be healthy
like wealthy wealthy so then money just
underwrites the cost of living a good
life it's not about the money for
money's sake money is a byproduct of
great works we put out to the world so
the money is what we get back and now we
can use this as the root system for how
it infiltrates the different parts of
our life so we can do great work and
live good lives so let me ask the
politically incorrect question um
working with men versus women do you see
that there's a different profile there
in general or is it pretty much the same
there it is a very different profile I
mean I I work equally with both but when
it comes to women women really are after
security and men are willing to take a
lot more risk so it's understanding that
when we understand this framework it
requires a certain amount of risk but
you're also building security but I
really love talking with women and
speaking with women because one thing
that we all tend to do but especially
women we abdicate our money we have this
mindset that we're not good at math
we're not good at money or something's
built in even women great at business
still have this mindset that they're not
good at the investing thing mhm so I
love just changing that mindset again
and just showing just how easy this
money thing is and that we're all
empowered we don't want to abdicate we I
mean I can't even if you're my personal
trainer you can't do my push-ups for me
I have to do my own P push-ups yet we're
saying with our money here take my money
and go make it do the push-ups versus
hey give me get some good coaching and
let me do my own money push-ups I had a
friend that used to say m time wish I
could hire somebody to exercise for me
yeah exactly don't we all right doesn't
work that way that's fascinating
well this has uh been very interesting
to look at and to kind of especially
deconstruct and decode the
entrepreneurial mind uh because uh my my
own personal experience and my own
experience from what I've witnessed uh
cooperates a lot of what you spoke about
and it's interesting you know that that
it had to be your own personal story
that led you you to what you're doing
today any final words for people who are
watching yeah the only final words is
just to to get good with your I mean
just get good with your money like your
money narrative get over any Hang-Ups
about it and just let it be what it is
which is this tool that we use that
underwrites our ability to live a good
life and and then do the work of what is
a good life and how much does it cost to
live it terrific well thanks so much for
sharing your your time and sharing your
experiences with us oh my pleasure thank
you hello hell and welcome to your
wealth breakthroughs episode 11 bonus
interview Ron Lynch has had a hand in
countless businesses GoPro being just
one high-profile example Ron has four
rules you absolutely must memorize
before you even think about starting a
business of your own most businesses
fail after all and these four rules
separate those that change lives from
those that have to close the doors pay
close attention to this interview with
Ron there's pure gold here for every
entrepreneur
[Music]
Ron I'm very much looking forward to
this conversation uh I have a feeling we
might be laughing a lot but we're going
to learn a lot too I hope so I'll
probably learn a lot so let's start with
your background tell us about how you
got to be doing what you're doing uh I
grew up in a normal American Family Two
school teachers for parents in Seattle
and I started out working in the grocery
business as a kid through high school
and oddly was fortunate enough to have a
roommate asked me if I wanted to
audition for a movie MH and I got a sag
card and I right off the street was
working with Robert Alman wow um who at
the time was a relatively big-time
Hollywood director and I got to go and
stay and uh work as a PA for a month too
and then uh that was parlayed into a
bunch of small movie parts
and I kept my job in the grocery
business and they were nice enough to
let me go periodically and work in films
so I did that periodically and then uh
on a film set one day I was uh I was
standing next to Jeff Bridges MH and you
know like as close as I could and I said
how do I get to be in your chair and he
said it's really easy make sure your
dad's Lloyd
Bridges like good response fair enough
yeah he said right if you can learn how
to write and writing was something I
hated doing and so I did it though I
went and bought Sid field screenplay and
I started writing screenplays at night
and I kept my job in the grocery store
and I worked my way up in the grocery
business to eventually become a store
director and an operations director
building new stores and managing stores
and during doing turnarounds and having
this nighttime passion of film making
and one of my friends was doing the
George Foreman grill mhm and uh said hey
I need some space in a grocery store to
do some man on the street and interviews
could we use your store and I said sure
and so they came in and we rented them
some space and through that I met George
Foreman's agent which Sam PE mutter and
optioned a movie to him and my friend
called me and said well you're kind of
resourceful and a week later I quit my
job and I was in the direct response
business wow so it's it was it really
kind of a weird kind of way to get there
but I ended up understanding pnls and
understanding marketing and film and put
those things together and manage to
Cobble a career out of that you
definitely have one of the most uh
unusual Minds I've encountered uh as
you're saying like you kind of have this
understanding over here this sort of
ability to write this ability to
communicate and understand how an
audience needs to listen I mean there's
really like this this strange skill set
that came together but what's also
interesting and I'm wondering just
philosophically how you feel about this
is that certain events crep up like you
know you happen you know to be running a
store or managing a store and then
happen to have a friend that's doing an
infomercial on the George Foreman grill
like if that didn't happen you know what
might the trajectory have been where
might you have gone do you ever think
about that yeah I do but I also have I'm
a big believer in making your own luck
because I left a little piece out which
is important I guess is that when Jeff
Bridges said right I started doing it
and I went home and I wrote two
screenplays now this is a small little
grocery store and I was not like I was a
grocery Checker at that point and I had
this customer that used to come through
all the time who was on a late afternoon
Talk Show in Seattle her name's Dana
Middleton very nice gal and I just said
to her one day I've written a couple of
movies and she said oh that's
interesting I said do you know anybody
that could help me she said well I might
bring in the screenplays and I think she
was curious as to whether I'd done the
work and this is a real lesson there's a
couple of real lessons in here for me is
do the work first I had done this
writing and most people in Hollywood
have an idea of screenplay but they
don't write it mhm so I I brought them
in I kept these screenplays under my
drawer and she she came in a couple days
later and I had him and I handed him to
her and she said how did you know to ask
me I said I didn't said well that's
weird because my sister is Kathleen
Kennedy and she's Steven Spielberg's
partner wow so I feel like I was on a
trajectory no matter what like there's a
destiny piece of this as well sure that
I really think that I was intended and
put here to do something and I was going
to crash into this airbag one way or the
other so that I think it there
Serendipity but there's hard work
associated with doing the work first and
I think in our culture there's a lot of
people that don't want to take risk or
invest themselves in something until
they get a reward or they see the reward
right and it doesn't work that way now
did you say that you optioned one of
those the one of those scripts the
second one I option to Sam prut who was
George Foreman's agent and it was a film
that I wrote called uh the real Vanessa
and it went on to not much a claim but
but it got sold and sold and sold and
sold but it got sold it got sold which
is pretty amazing yeah so what are most
of your business activities today so
I've spent the last 20 years helping
people launch businesses and direct
response primarily and then I got to a
point where I could invest in them so
the it started out as getting a little
bit of wealth and then starting to
invest and getting a knack for knowing
what works finding what products work
and I think that is relational to what
you said about looking from the customer
perspective I have some Harden fast
rules that help me select products that
I know are going to be winners so I
don't sign up for things that don't
serve the market place what kind of
rules there's four key things in my mind
that you have to have to even get in any
business and the first thing I do is I
sit down and do a creative brief and
strategic brief and I write these things
out you have to have in my opinion an
innovation innovation is gives you
something to a problem to solve for the
customer that's useful to them and the
reason I say Innovation is you can sell
things that are Commodities but
Commodities don't have the second thing
you need which is margin because if you
don't have margin you can't market and
fuel a business so it's not worth
getting into and I just don't know how
to sell Commodities and I stay out of
commodity markets when it comes to
consumer goods mhm the third thing is
audience someone has to be on the
receiving end of this who really wants
it so add those things up and if you
have quality you have something you can
sell and what I add is the fourth
element which is story and story relates
the Innovation and builds the value that
makes them accept the
margin and connect personally with them
as an audience does that make sense it
makes a lot of sense and story which you
know I guess is kind of you know writing
in the world that you came from telling
a story Etc uh seems to be is that would
you say like the Catalyst it's sort of
like the X Factor that can take those
other elements and bring them to life
and turn them into big successes yeah
there there's two things that that
relate to that I think one is taking the
story and having it be about the
customer um I think that marketing
should be a mirror that people should
see themselves in your product and
should see themselves in the marketing
and so many people want to sell
something they have a they're like
here's my thing and they want to start
talking about their features nobody
wants your features or as interested
people buy benefits M and the benefit to
them so that's to me that's kind of
instrumental is can we tell a story
about that product that works for them
and the second thing is a character
trait um and the internet has really
made this happen years ago at Wharton if
somebody went to business school they
say hey your your company and your brand
has to have five values and we're going
to have these five pillars we're going
to sell these five pillars well the
internet has truncated media you get
inundated with so many messages as a
consumer they may not get to any five
messages and I think that things that
accelerate rapidly like I had a hand in
GoPro MH what made that go was having
the product be kind of a merit badge if
there's a core character trait that you
adopt when you bring the product onto
yourself you have a really good shot at
winning and at GoPro I think people
think of it as an adventure camera and a
sports camera and it is all of those
things but when you utilize the product
it's about bravery and you get this
character trait of Bravery for owning it
that's kind of the badge you put on
yourself no doubt as you're saying it
and you know being a GoPro owner and you
know seeing their ads and their videos
you you walk in they're showing a video
it's that's exactly what now comes to
mind which was a subtext to me until you
just made it explicit so really really
interesting so is this a a knack a
learned skill I mean how how does
somebody get to recognize these types of
things and and act upon them and be
effective I thought it was an act for a
long time as you grow a company and
you're trying to train writers and train
cinematographers and trying to get
producers to to help you and I thought I
was really egotistical when I was young
and I thought oh this is all me and then
people started asking me questions like
how do you get creative how do you
select products and I started I wrote a
book a long time ago and then I
developed a training program for people
and I've been utilizing that training
program for a couple of years now and
people step into it and I've learned the
there's actually metrics there's there's
awareness that you can create in a
person if they go through these steps
they're going to be able to discover
like the four things I just described to
you and ultimately if they get good at
that then they'll find these character
traits and that's what helps a product
go from zero to a billion rapidly is
getting something that's so solid that
the audience starts selling your story
for you so now with the way that you
approach business and the things that
you've done and like you said you maybe
you learn the four traits understand how
to get people to start telling your
story for you Etc and these are key
elements to uh growth and maybe even
explosive growth of a of a company yep
um how much is following the um the
algorithm if you will you know the
sequence do this do this do this get
this to happen make that happen where
does mindset play into all this how does
the head space of the entrepreneur or
the business owner play into whether or
not this is going to work I think when I
when I was young I did what most young
people do and I was looking to take
something from the world I was trying to
extract money and find money and take it
and what I discovered over time that
that's not how this works money operates
in two ways you can either earn money or
you can make money and most people use
those words interchangeably and they're
not the same thing earning money is
providing value to somebody and getting
a wage for it whether it's hourly and
that's I don't care if you're a grocery
Checker or a lawyer that's generally how
we think of transactional economy MH but
making money is what JK rling did M she
had an idea in her head she wrote a book
that became movies and Harry Potter is a
billion doll Enterprise that came out of
the thin air and that's what people who
pump oil out of the ground do that's
what people who build construction do
they bring assets to the world and when
you create an asset the world recognizes
that asset as having value then it can
be collateralized mhm and if it sooner
or later it will be it gets transformed
into collateral at some point and then
the minute it does a bank will print $9
for every dollar in that bank so now it
begs the question saying oh boy I've
been earning money my whole life how do
I make the transition from earning to
making money I and I think it's creation
I think that that um being a person that
can go find a problem in the world or a
situation where you can add and really
benefit people with a real solution that
they'll grab and carry on for themselves
I like what Sarah Blake is one of my
favorite people um and what she did with
Spanx was amazing she took something
that actually existed years ago the
girdle right and the girl went away it
became unfashionable for 20 years and
she brought it back and made it a piece
of an apparel a piece of apparel that
was acceptable and smart and slimming
and
sexy and once people grabbed on to that
and understood what it was and how it
made you look great in clothes no matter
your size it exploded and certainly you
know having Oprah as a fan didn't hurt
you know obviously not but here's what's
really interesting uh because the
context that's created in the marketing
the girdle is seen as something
oppressive right women having to wear a
girdle to look right for a man was like
an oppressive thing so how do you make
the transition say wait a minute this is
this is smart and sexy not oppressive
here well here's it's I think here's the
psychological difference is the
assumption that women are getting
dressed for men is actually an incorrect
assumption women are getting dressed for
each other and if you think about that
it's true when you go someplace some
with your spouse sometimes she probably
doesn't care that much sometimes about
how she looks when she's with you but
when she's going to be with other women
in the tribe she takes a little extra
care and that's natural I mean that's we
don't talk about it a lot CU it's
awkward but I think that as a marketer
that's one of the important things you
need to do is have find a tasteful way
to have an awkward conversation with
your customer because what you're really
talking about then is a problem right
and you're solving it so I I think that
that's probably why that worked so well
any other examples of that like how like
is Ed maybe another awkward conversation
or are there other examples that you
have where people have taken something
that's kind of like awkward maybe
difficult to Market and turn it into a
big business I think that it happens all
of the time but it's that's the secret
to something from going from zero to a
billion fast and most businesses don't
get that that's you know 80 to 90% of
businesses don't but when you're lining
something up originally like if you can
figure that out up front you've got a
really great shot of having something
accelerate I'll give you an example in
toys is kind of a place Razor scooters
took off yeah really rapidly um jobs in
the phone the iPhone like there were
cellular phones and the way Jobs made
Apple come back was really kind of
through the back door he did it with
music mhm he went and he got he created
this device the iPod and got everybody
on music and it was very emotional to
them mhm and then he went what if I put
this with a phone with a screen and he
just absolutely devoured the phone
market and he as a brilliant marketer he
went how do I know let people know what
phones in their pocket white headphones
M so he put something iconic that made
you cool MH related to music and you
remember back then like Bono was the
outline for iTunes forever right like he
he knew how to place something in your
mind and make you want want to do it so
he's not you're not selling something at
that point you're creating desire and
that's a different game yeah if you can
get good at creating
desire you're brilliant and he was so
I'm now getting sort of the Run Lynch
rules of marketing or the you know
marketing principles are there other
ones that you would Cho here I think
that empathy and speaking with empathy
to your your customer again I'm not
looking to extract I'm looking to
provide so I think that when you
approach the world from that perspective
and you approach your company or your
product from what can we actually do to
make a difference for this person you
just are going to have an easier
business model because it's going to
propagate itself you talked about money
and you know gave the distinction
between earning money making money how
important is it for people to really
Define their philosophy around money
success wealth and how might that drive
their actions and outcomes well I think
that people think money equals something
in fact I ask this question to people a
lot I say hey money equals what and when
if you ask somebody what money equals
they'll say oh Freedom or more time or
more opportunity or more choices and
money equals is actually a math question
if I asked you what seven equals would
you say more time or more freedom it
does doesn't make it's actually not
cognitively doesn't make sense and when
someone announces what money equals to
them they're usually announcing what
they don't have in their life they don't
feel they have freedom or they don't
feel they have time or they don't feel
they have choices and the fact of the
matter is if you do make that a
Pythagorean equation and you say zero
money does that mean zero Freedom zero
choices zero time it doesn't right it's
not true and what money is is a
byproduct resource MH and you have about
20 resources and the first 10 are in
maso's hierarchy and the second 10 are
emotional they're observational is what
do I see that that the tribe has a
problem with that'll get me into the
tribe by curing like the medicine man
and the chief are the highest in the
tribe they probably work the least but
they
provide specificity that the tribe needs
the medicine man heals people so there's
10 Hunters to one Medicine Man and that
Dynamic exists in our culture still that
the doctor and then the worker are
separated economically right so how do
you think in a way that translates that
value of my second 10 resources empathy
problem solving creativity and those are
the people that end up really succeeding
or people that go it isn't about me it's
about the problem that I can solve
creatively for other people and they'll
see value in that and eight or nine
things happen before money happens I
think I saw I saw Garrett Gunderson who
I adore say money's the receipt and he's
absolutely right money is the last thing
that happens in the transaction but when
you're hungry for it it's the first
thing that happens in your mind right
and you're reversing cause and effect
which you you're starting starting off
on the wrong foot when you do that do
you find that culturally there have been
shifting Sands as far as let's say the
the kind of work that you did uh let's
say that it was 1980s and what were the
rules of the 90s versus 2000s like
there's different I think cultural
sentiments that you have to maybe be
sensitive to to be able to go to market
and you and promote or Market or do the
things that you do um are you seeing
that those have shifted a lot and do you
think that Trends are changing right now
well Trends are always changing the
shape of the earth is always changing
when it comes to marketing and culture
that's why it's culture but I think
inside of
that
sphere it goes too it cuts both ways
like I work very hard to have a very
cohesive brand umbrella or message
around products that I work with but
underneath it there's all these customer
verticals that 20 years ago I couldn't
address on television CU it had to work
on television so you could only tell one
story now I can tell 20 stories just as
long as it fits under that umbrella and
so I can get much more personal with the
customer and talk to them about them
directly so I love internet marketing I
love multiple channels on television I I
think that we're actually in a way kind
of going 100 years backwards to the
magazine model where you would have one
type of AD in one type of magazine if
you were a big brand and a different one
in a different magazine and we're kind
of going backwards so they're they're
stealing from the past to place into the
future and that's that's a really
interesting thing uh because you'd say
well is television the future of
Television marketing and advertising is
is there a future there do you think
it's declining so obviously you're
seeing this huge opportunity it's always
bigger it's always and people I I have
people say infomercials don't work I'm
like well that's not all I do
anymore but apparently there's $6
billion dollars of media time being
bought in that space every year W so
they work uh it's just people have a
better chance of finding themselves and
they're looking for themselves so they
just pass stuff that doesn't work and
you'll see I mean you like I'm sure that
you see people that say I don't like
advertising or it doesn't to me I hate
being sold right people don't hate being
sold they be they hate being sold things
they don't like right they love to be
sold themselves and so that's if you're
always focused on it being about them
and being a mirror you've got a great
chance so how do you do that do you pick
specific avatars who's our viewer this
is what they're interested in um do you
think that the narrow if you narrow the
scope it's more effective than trying to
cast a wider net what's your philosophy
on that so I'll typically look at a
product go really what problem does it
solve and the usually the pro the
manufacturer and sometimes I'm the
manufacturer we look at the features
really deeply because that's where every
manufacturer wants to start and then I
try to assign a benefit to each one of
those features or maybe three benefits
When you back away and you look at that
list you go okay now who wants that
benefit and you'll find four or five
avatars and so I'll create custom
advertising and messaging for those
avatars about them and they may have
offers or asks from the company to learn
more get more try more whatever it is
based on them I always feel like we're
Ginger Rogers we always have to dance
backwards and high heels from the
customer and of course uh knowing our
viewer I wonder if they're going to know
who that
is we're dating ourselves a little bit
Yeah well so yeah Ginger Rogers is old
enough to be my dead grandmother but but
we still know who she yeah so what is
maybe the biggest Revelation that you've
had say in the past five or seven years
in the work you're doing saying wow this
is a new aha this is this is something
that has now accelerated My Success
because I learned this thing I think
that I used to complicate things and I
think being very simple and very clear
and being very honest with the customer
MH and I think that that it kind of you
kind of alluded to it like how's the the
market changed I think people associate
direct marketing with things of yester
year and go oh they think of the yell
and cell and the Billy mazes and who was
a friend of mine and who I adored but I
don't think that functionally works
anymore so I think the audience just
wants to be told the truth and be
treated fairly and I I love that the
internet requires you to do that now
because if you're if you're not nice in
business you're going to get found out
and people are going to start talking
about it and you're not going to be in
business so uh I think that that's great
at the same time this niching down and
the accessibility of people of the
internet allows the little guy to act
like a big guy and that's what's really
exciting to me is that any person like I
know five people in my life that have
come to me for advice and they were not
what I would consider to be business
people and two years later they have
five and10 million businesses because
they were just smart and followed the
strategy that we gave them and they just
did the steps and it's really neat that
we have friends that are in the coffee
business or in hair care or in shoe care
and you're like this person would not
have ever had a chance 20 years ago and
now you can and no matter what the
business might be I guess the same rules
apply whether it's coffee or hair care
or any of the other things that you
described uh because people think oh
well you know my business is sort of a
it's quirky or it's Unique but there
have to be I guess the fundamental
elements that are going to apply no
matter what the business is well it's
really I you know in my course I have a
I have a doctor that's in the course
right now you think what would a what if
a physician like how would this apply to
a physician and she called me the other
day and she goes I've actually my
practice is growing like crazy because
of these principles I'm sitting down
with my customers and I'm having a
conversation about their needs their
benefits and I'm just taking the time to
ask and then going would this work or
would that work and there were just
really empathetic
questions and offers and sometimes
people don't realize that their business
has an offer like doctors you don't
think of doctors as having an offer but
they do oh yeah and she's able to get
people enrolled into Healthcare programs
that are better for their health and
they're getting a real benefit in their
life you go okay how the infom marcial
guys helping a physician I didn't expect
that and it's wonderful so does this get
back to that uh that Innovation thing
that you're talking about where you take
a traditional business like a doctor's
office and it's very confined in its
thinking and approach this is just the
way it's done and now here you've got a
guy like you that can work you know with
a doctor completely different seemingly
irrelevant Industries to each other and
they can now start to open up say oh
there's better ways for me to achieve a
higher level service and result for my
people that I serve yeah and the crazy
thing is I I feel like I I would love to
be able to claim that I have a PhD in
Psychiatry or psychology based upon
these years of learning but I learned it
in the field and I've learned it with
real people so in a way I feel like I
have that knowledge but I've got it from
these interactions and yeah the it's
applicable to humans are humans whether
they're doctors whether they're plumbers
it doesn't humans are humans and the all
of these needs that people have
psychologically to be seen to be heard
and to be cared for are Universal well
what's interesting is you know I guess
along these lines and this is where I'm
saying well you this this guy's got a
very different and interesting mind the
way that it processes so earlier you
know you were here you know in part to
do this interview
we happened to with some of our team be
working on a completely different
project had nothing to do with why you
were here Etc and you happen to kind of
hear about what we're doing we're
wrestling with something that we want to
do and suddenly you just said oh this
this this and this and I'm sitting there
saying how how could you just riff that
not even know the project not even been
a part of it not understood it but
instantly just dialed into saying this
is what you need to say so that they'll
listen to you and you were 100% right I
mean it was just blatantly obvious so so
did you teach yourself just to uh create
that kind of empathy and understanding
of of a particular audience because you
can apply it to anything because like I
said this was a different topic you
weren't you weren't uh up to speed on
the topic but yet boom you nailed
exactly what we needed to do so is that
is that something that you trained
yourself to do I think that there's some
nature and and some nurture to that when
I met Jeff Hayes for the first time we
we spoke at a conference and we all had
to introduce ourselves and it was to a
pretty prestigious group of people and
it was finally got to me and he I'm you
know with these really successful
filmmakers and I'm the you know the TV
commercial guy or whatever and I got
they got to me and they said well I'm as
I'm as dumb as your dumbest
Customer because and I feel like I am
that way I feel like I'm I feel like I'm
a little bit Savant is that I'm just
empathetic and I think about like you I
listened to what you guys were doing I
just said well I'm a customer what do I
need to hear if I if you were enrolling
me in this what would I really need to
hear and it's not in a manipulative way
it's just I have some questions can you
answer them and and I think this is the
interesting thing I think people are
looking for how can I best manipulate
you know the emotions of my audience to
turn a prospect into a customer or
something but what you did was give us a
better way to tell the truth about what
we were delivering it was just a more
compelling way to understand it cuz what
I was thinking before you spoke was in
Ade equate to really communicate what we
had and you you just said oh you you
brought to like you said it was simple
was very compelling and it was also 100%
true yeah so that and that I guess it
seems like it's simple but it's not easy
but it has to do with Integrity is that
what are you going to deliver I mean I
think Integrity is that you do what you
say you're going to do but you also said
tell people what you're not going to do
and when you can establish that
relationship with the customer really
quick they can identify it because
you're pummeled with 40 to 60,000
marketing messages a week and your brain
is this incredible sorting device that
is pushing away everything that's not
pertinent or relative to you because
your brain's in its core is in survival
mode so if that's what it's doing and
pushing all that that stuff away how do
I become relevant and being relevant is
saying do you have this need M and they
identify the need and then you go on to
explain that you can possibly solve it
and you can't do that falsely yeah
they're smart the the best TV producer
in this room right now MH is the viewer
at the other end of the camera they're
better at it than you and I are and so I
tend to look at it from the consumer's
perspective in every chance I get if I
were to ask you what's your purpose have
you clarified that for me personally yes
I have and my purpose is um I i' I found
man and I found God so I've got that
solved for myself now my purpose is
literally to help other people clear
that out in their own radio in their
head and kind of get home like I think
that that that's our responsibility to
each other is to care for each other and
if you make a lot of money you have a
huge responsibility to do something good
with it and if you have opportunity or
someone you can help you need to do that
you just have an obligation and so
that's my that's my mission is to teach
people how to ethically make money to
teach people how to ethically set up a
business that will be successful cuz
there's just mechanical things that
anybody can learn so if I can do those
two things and be a little bit of a
mench I'm good you use the phrase get
home which I think I know what you mean
but speak about that some more I I think
that we are to some degree living in The
Matrix that and we all have our version
of that we all we all are looking
through our own lens at what that Matrix
is but at the core people are good and
want to be good and there's a greater
good there's a being that created us
there's a God that loves us and I'm not
embarrassed to say that I believe in
that cuz it's as in my mind as
complicated to believe in nothing and a
little depressing yeah and I like to
feel loved and I like to feel that I
have I'm receiving through my radio a
broadcast signal that's useful to other
people I want to be useful and that
drives you it's fun yeah so you've been
at this for a lot of years and it's fun
still absolutely what keeps it fun it's
always new I I got to get up every day
to see what happens in the next episode
right and I'll tell you things I I still
like people I think that people watch
programming like this and they think oh
those those folks have it made nobody
has it made and if somebody's saying
they have it made they're lying to you I
still have problems I still have I worry
about my kids I've like I I'll tell you
an admission like something that's odd
to talk about I'm going in to have some
cancer removed in that in a week or so
w but I'm not giving that any power I'm
not scared or nervous about that I'm
going to go in I'm going to get it done
then I'm going to put my mind in the
place that heals myself during the
holidays and then I'm going to get back
to work wow so what is the practice or
discipline that can give you that kind
of mindset cuz now we're back to the
mindset thing and we could see that that
the mindset the philosophy is driving
your whole process here keeping it fun
keeping it stimulating having you move
through challenge as compared to be
defeated by challenge so do you have a
practice or discipline that that helps
you uh maintain or develop that so I do
some weird things perfect I like weird
okay so I do some weird things um I wake
up at 4:00 every morning and and I list
mentally what I would like to get done
so my projects if I'm I'm typically
working on three or four marketing
projects and writing a book or doing
something so I list for that day what I
want to do and what I want to accomplish
and then start to problem solve like if
I'm going to write dialogue for uh a
book or write dialogue for a TV show I
start to work on that and I put my head
back on the pillow and I kind of get in
Delta State for about 3 hours and I
literally do my entire job and do my
entire day from 4:00 to 7:00 on my
pillow kind of in Delta wow and then I
get up and by 11:30 I've done it and the
rest of the day I solve other people's
problems then the phone starts ringing
and people start calling me but I've
been highly productive doing that for
the last 10 years and before I go to bed
if I have a real issue or problem I was
once in a situation that was very nearly
a really bad lawsuit mhm and that can be
very grading like you're very upset
about being done wrong or whatever that
is and I started to keep really good
notes and once I started keeping notes
then I could put that aside and I knew
if I never if I ever needed to access it
I could access it but I didn't have to
process it and obsess on it and so I've
learned to put my problems on a notepad
and go I know that they're there I know
what the story is if I need to deal with
that I'll go deal with it when the time
comes and then I can go back to put and
it's a
I'm really talking about is where do you
put your attention cuz that's what's
going to grow wherever you put your
light that's what's going to grow you
put your light on your problems you can
put your light on Solutions you can p
put your light on growing other people
some people have to just do their own
business and grow it huge I like working
in four or five businesses at a time and
my in my business model I end up owning
stock in a whole bunch of companies you
know it's interesting when you talk
about that I think David Allen you the
getting things done guy you know that
that's one of his primary premises is
you got to get the stuff out of your
brain you know just and so that what a
practice to say Hey you know if I got
something in there I put on notepad and
it gives me the security that I don't
have to constantly be reminding myself
oh I got to remember that any other
practices well again this kind of
relates to that but think about this one
of the most important things I do is
sleep MH which sounds nuts because we're
all thinking about what do we accomplish
but we're wired to sleep like 30% of the
time why that's a really important thing
and that's the first thing people start
to cut into in their life they start to
deprive themselves of that and I think
that the number one thing that you have
in your life is your mind mhm and the
number one place that you reboot clean
the disc repair and do your storage and
you defrag is while you're sleeping do
that correctly and then you can get up
and do other things correctly so to me
it's all the it's all the downtime
things that actually provide me the
energy to do the uptime things yeah D
loing is is absolutely essential and I
think a lot of entrepreneurs it's like
they almost like brag about oh you know
I only sleep four or five hours a night
or you know they talk about how you know
many hours they can put in uh but what I
loved in what you said is that you are
tapping i' say unusual resources saying
hey I'm up at 4:00 kind of put it into
my mind and then go back to sleep for
three hours in the Delta State or maybe
it's not sleep but in a Delta State and
then by 11:30 I've really got my
achievement for the day and then the
rest of the day can be more rea acve to
other things so and it seems like this
kind of a process then go through that
and then get good sleep and then get in
flow it's get in flow yeah and I can get
in flow and I like I can I can write a
book in five or six days I can write a
screenplay in three or four days wow
just and it's not that many hours it's
getting into that flow State and but to
me there's there's this you still have
to have relationships you still have to
have people in your life and if you you
know sleep get up do your work then deal
with the people so there's a lot of
people who have ambition
they want to develop wealth they want to
do something good or maybe even great in
the world um and uh and they they're
they're finding themselves foiled in
their attempts maybe a time or two or
multiple times what advice you have for
them so everything that I've learned
I've learned through my failures now
I've launched
300 products and 70 Brands over 20 years
but I have a ton of failures and the
weird thing is
is everybody who
fails the failures aren't what the crowd
remembers they remember your
championships and you got to remember
that that nobody's going to be focused
on your failures when you finally hit it
out of the park they're going to
remember the home run you know a great
baseball player hits
327 fails 70% of the time right and that
that's how we are wired and if you look
at if you look externally at somebody
else's success and you think that and
you've one think think it's monetary
success and that's the only measure you
make you haven't measured everything mhm
so you haven't really measured success
you've measured an illusion or a mirage
or an aspect and I I think that that
failure is so
profound the second thing is you don't
have to have all your own failures right
and that's what I loved about the I love
about the films that you guys make
because I you know now I've had the
opportunity like I watch the entire
money reveal every second of money
revealed I watched what I learned from
that saved me probably 20 years there
were things so many things in there that
were not like nuggets but were like
sound principled things that I had no
clue about and I I think most people
considered me successful yeah and I'm
like I didn't know that or that and I
suddenly I got all of these I'll take
all those arrows and put them in my
quiver absolutely and I'll I'll use them
and I think that's the other thing is
like go learn yeah isn't it isn't it
interesting that you know people who
really get successful one of the things
I see they have in common is that they
don't just learn from their own mistakes
but they make it their business to learn
from other people's they're out there
searching for that and and that prevents
these harder lessons uh and moves into
success quicker yeah and I when I I I'll
sit down and have dinner with folks like
yourself and you'll ask me a question or
I'll ask you a question you'll say I
don't know yeah and that's a good sign
to me that I'm dealing with a good like
someone who's solid like you can't know
everything about everything and people
that say I don't know I'm really
attracted to because they tend to be
curious too and I love curiosity is Big
to me and I like people that are humble
and curious and like well-intentioned is
there anything that you're not doing in
your career or life in general right now
that you wish you were um I have one
project that has been in mothballs for a
few years cuz techn techology hadn't
caught up to it m and it couldn't be in
the marketplace and we're just pulling
kind of the canvas off of that and
starting to assemble this and it's
something I'm going to be devoted to for
the next three or four years that I'm
very excited about I could tell you're
very excited I can't wait to see what it
is well I feel like Ronica talked to you
for many hours um and I really
appreciate you sharing all this wisdom
you have a a like I said really an
unusual background unique context and
experience and it it's been very
gracious for you to come here and sit
down and share it oh thank you it's it's
it's fun to get to know you guys and I I
really appreciate the time to see the
first episode in wealth breakthroughs
and start at the start check the video
right there next to me I think you'll
love it continue to believe and I'll see
you there what is it I look for in a in
a business and how do I identify great
opportunities it's got to be a win-win
situation and and business I learned if
it's just for you it's not going to last
very long